OK, so a couple of physicists walk into a bar. Just kidding. They're not at a bar. They're at a school. Scientists in training.
好的，有两位物理学家走进了一家酒吧。开个玩笑。他们没在酒吧，而是在学校里。他们是未来的科学家。
I'm sure this story seems strange to you, but to me, it was just-- you know, this was just like another day in the physics world.
我敢说这个故事听起来很奇怪，但对我来说，它仅仅是……你知道，这就像物理学界的寻常一天。
David Kestenbaum used to live in physics world. These days he lives in our world. You can hear him in our world as part of NPR'S Planet Money team, reporting on economics. But at the time of the story, he was getting a PhD in high-energy particle physics at, um-- there's no way to avoid the name-droppy-ness of what I'm about to say-- at Harvard University. But to paraphrase Us Magazine , Harvard physicists, in certain ways around the office, they're just like us.
大卫·肯斯滕鲍姆曾生活在物理学界。现在他生活在我们的世界里。你可以在我们的世界听到他，作为美国国家公共电台（NPR）《星球货币》团队的一员报道经济新闻。但在那个故事发生时，他正在哈佛大学攻读高能粒子物理学博士学位。嗯，我接下来要说的话难免有炫耀学校之嫌。不过，套用《美国周刊》的话来说，哈佛的物理学家们在某些方面和办公室里的人一样，他们也和我们没两样。
There was always a time of day when someone made a pot of very strong coffee, and afterwards, everyone drank the coffee and then didn't quite want to work yet. And so we all stood around and talked about various things. You know, and there was a blackboard or a whiteboard or something there. And we were talking about how nobody really had girlfriends.
每天总有那么个时候，有人会煮上一壶非常浓的咖啡，之后，大家喝完咖啡，又不太想立刻干活。于是我们都站着聊天，谈论各种事情。你知道的，当时那里有个黑板或白板之类的东西。我们在谈论大家都还没女朋友的事。
So, this being physics world, the next logical thing to do was to employ the power of mathematics to estimate the likelihood of finding a girlfriend. And so they start jotting down a calculation.
既然是在物理学界，接下来合乎逻辑的做法就是运用数学力量来估算找到女朋友的概率。于是他们开始在板子上记下计算过程。
I guess it's sort of a variation on-- you know this thing called the Drake equation?
我想这算是某种变体，你知道那个叫“德雷克方程”的东西吗？
No.
不知道。
That is a way to estimate how many planets are out there that have intelligent life on them.
那是一种估算宇宙中存在多少地外智慧生命行星的方法。
OK, so in this Drake equation, apparently you start with how many stars are in the universe. That is, all the places where there might be life. And then you subtract out all the stars that don't have planets around them, right? Because there can't be life there.
好吧，在这个德雷克方程里，显然你是从宇宙中有多少颗恒星开始计算的。也就是说，所有可能存在生命的地方。然后你要减去所有周围没有行星的恒星，对吧？因为那里不可能有生命。
And then you subtract out all the planets that are too far from the sun or too close to the sun to support life. And so on and so on-- you get the idea-- until finally, you come up with the likelihood of a planet with life evolved to the point of intelligence. OK.
接着你要减去所有距离太阳太远或太近而无法维持生命的行星。如此类推，以此类推——你懂的——直到最后，你得出了一个行星演化出智慧生命的概率。好吧。
They ran the same kind of math now, except-- and I realize this is going to sound a little strange. It says they replaced intelligent life with girlfriends.
他们现在用了同样的数学方法，只不过——我知道这听起来有点奇怪。他们把“智慧生命”换成了“女朋友”。
So we started to do the calculation on the board. And, uh-- can you look up what the population in Boston is?
所以我们开始在黑板上进行计算。还有……你能查一下波士顿的人口是多少吗？
Now David is asking me to look this up because at this point in our interview, I actually made him run the math for me, with real numbers that we got from the internet. So he started with the population of Boston, because he and his fellow physics students wanted girlfriends in Boston, where they all live. Population of Boston, I found online, was a little under 600,000.
大卫现在让我查这个，是因为在采访的这个时候，我确实让他用我们从网上得到的真实数据为我演示了计算过程。所以他从波士顿的人口开始，因为他和他的物理系同学想要在他们居住的波士顿找女朋友。我在网上查到波士顿的人口略低于60万。
So you start with 600,000, which sounds great, except that half of them are guys, right? And I'm only interested in girls.
所以从60万开始，听起来不错，但其中一半是男性，对吧？而我只对女性感兴趣。
OK, so it's 300,000.
好吧，那就是30万。
And then I want people-- let's be honest, probably within 10 years of my age or something, right?
然后我想要那种……说实话，大概年龄在跟我相差10岁以内的吧？
OK, so 10 years on either side, so that means--
好的，前后10岁，那意味着——
I'm actually looking at some numbers here. Looks like-- looks like if you go from 20 to 40, you're talking-- that's still like 35% of the population, a third or something.
我正在看一些数据。看起来……如果年龄范围在20到40岁之间，那大概是总人口的35%，也就是三分之一左右。
So that means that out of 300,000 women, that leaves 100,000 in his age range. These being doctoral students, they wanted girlfriends who were college grads. Well, OK, about 25% of Americans over 25 years old have graduated from college. That knocks out roughly 3/4 of these women.
这意味着在30万女性中，他这个年龄段的还有10万。作为博士生，他们想要大学生女朋友。嗯，好吧，25岁以上的美国人中约有25%大学毕业。这剔除了这批女性中的大约四分之三。
Ouch.
哎哟。
So you're down to-- we were at 100,000. So you're down to 25,000.
所以剩下……我们刚才算到10万。所以你只剩下2.5万了。
Then you start applying stuff like, you know, how often are they single?
然后你开始运用一些条件，比如，你知道，她们单身的概率是多少？
Yeah. Let's say half of them are single. So now you're down to 12,500.
是的。假设她们中有一半是单身。现在你就只剩下1.25万人了。
Yeah, see? It's getting scary now, right?
你看，现在开始变得可怕了吧？
And then of course you get to how many people are actually attractive to you. And even if you give a really high percentage, like one in five, OK, that knocks your pool of candidates down from 12,500 to 2,500.
然后当然还要考虑有多少人是你真正觉得有吸引力的。即使你给出一个很高的比例，比如五分之一，那也会把你候选人的池子从1.25万缩减到2500人。
In the whole city of Boston, right?
在整个波士顿市？
Yeah.
是的。
That's just like a needle in a haystack.
那简直就像大海捞针。
And that 2,500 is before you get to anything personal, like your religion or how you see the world. What's your sense of humor? So David and his fellow students are talking about this, these rather kind of depressing numbers. And one of the professors comes in.
而那2500人甚至还没算上任何个性化的因素，比如你的宗教信仰或世界观。你的幽默感如何？所以大卫和他的同学们就在讨论这个，这些相当令人沮丧的数字。这时一位教授走了进来。
She's not married, either. And so we start to draw it for her, and then we started to say, well OK, half of them are men, so we'd circle half. And then we'd say, well, what's the age group you're interested in? And then we'd sort of circle a smaller subset. And then she had all these other requirements, like the guy had to be taller than her. And she's pretty tall.
她也没结婚。于是我们开始为她推算，然后我们说，好吧，假设一半是男性，我们就圈掉一半。然后说，好吧，你感兴趣的年龄段是多少？然后我们又圈掉一个更小的子集。接着她还有其他要求，比如男生必须比她高。而她个子挺高的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That really limited things. And then she said he had to be smarter than her. You know, and she's a Harvard physics professor, so that was even smaller. And basically, we got down to there being nobody.
这真的限制很大。然后她说他必须比她聪明。你知道的，她是哈佛的物理学教授，所以符合条件的人就更少了。基本上，我们算到最后一个人都不剩。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
She's alone.
她孤身一人。
During this period of your life when you would think about these numbers, were you sure the entire time that there was somebody out there?
在你思考这些数字的人生阶段里，你一直确定世界上有某个人存在吗？
Yeah. I don't know why. But you know, at the beginning of every mathematical proof, people often write, "Assume that there exists X." Assume we have an infinite surface bound by something, or whatever.
是的。我不知道为什么。但你知道，在每个数学证明的开头，人们通常会写“假设存在X”。假设我们有一个被某种东西包围的无限平面，等等。
Right.
没错。
It's like, assume there exists some girlfriend. There's totally that act of faith underneath it, yeah. But I had a more scientific view, which is that there are people out there who might be right for me, not just one person. Like that seemed like in a silly novel or something. You know.
就像是，假设存在某个女朋友。那种信念之下完全是一种信心。但我有更科学的观点，那就是世界上有很多人可能适合我，不只是一个人。那种“唯一一个”的想法就像愚蠢小说里的情节。你知道的。
Yeah.
是啊。
I don't believe there's just one. If there were just one person out there, good luck. They could speak Chinese, you know?
我不相信只有一个。如果世界上真的只有一个人，祝你好运。她可能还会说中文呢，你知道吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And they probably do, right? What are the odds you're going to find them and a translator? You got to believe there's more than one person.
而且很可能就是这样，对吧？你找到她还要顺便找个翻译的概率是多少？你必须相信不止一个人。
But if you do believe that there is more than one person for you, you really might want to keep that belief to yourself sometimes. This may be one of those ideas that you don't want to take out of the classroom and bring into the real world. Case in point.
但如果你真的相信有不止一个人适合你，有时你最好还是把这个信念藏在心里。这可能是那种你不该带出课堂、带进现实世界的想法。举个例子。
It was definitely early on in our relationship. And I think it was our first big fight.
那绝对是在我们关系的早期。我想那是我们的第一次大争吵。
This is somebody else from the immediate word of our radio show-- Alex Blumberg, one of our producers. A while ago, he and his then future wife, Nazanin, were out on a date. And because they were newly in love, the topic of conversation was--
这是我们电台节目组里的另一个人——我们的制片人之一，亚历克斯·布伦伯格。不久前，他和当时的未婚妻纳扎宁正在约会。因为他们刚陷入热恋，谈话的主题是——
How great it was that we were in love. [LAUGHS] And how happy we were to have found each other. And it felt so fated, you know?
我们相爱是多么美好。[笑] 以及我们找到彼此是多么幸运。而且感觉真是命中注定，你知道吗？
And she asked, do you really think that we were the only one for each other? And I said, I don't know if you're the only one for me, but I think that you have to be at least one in 100,000, is what I said. Which I thought was-- in retrospect, now that I'm telling this story, that sounds really bad.
她问，你真的认为我们是彼此的唯一吗？我说，我不知道你是不是我的唯一，但我认为你至少是10万分之一，我是这么说的。回想起来，当我讲这个故事时，我觉得那听起来真的很糟糕。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I was kind of holding my tongue over here, actually. Yeah.
其实我在旁边一直在咬舌头强忍着。是啊。
At the time, I thought it was a romantic statement. Because one out of 100,000-- what is there, like 6 or 7 billion people on the planet?
当时，我觉得那是一个浪漫的陈述。因为10万分之一——地球上有60亿还是70亿人？
Sure.
当然。
He picked 100,000, which probably doesn't make any scientific sense and also made me feel bad.
他选了10万分之一，这可能没有任何科学意义，而且也让我感觉很不好。
So if Alex thought that saying that there are 100,000 other women that he could love was simply another way of saying how rare love is-- 100,000 seemed like a small number to Alex. Nazanin did not see it that way.
所以，如果亚历克斯认为说“还有10万个他可能爱上的女性”仅仅是表达爱是多么罕见的一种方式——10万对亚历克斯来说似乎是个小数目。纳扎宁可不这么看。
I know it's ridiculous to think that there's one person out there for everybody, but it definitely feels that way, right? When you're, like, falling in love. And it's not like I actually expect him to believe it, but he wouldn't even say it. [LAUGHS]
我知道认为每个人都有一个“唯一”是很荒谬的，但那种感觉确实是那样的，对吧？当你坠入爱河的时候。并不是说我真的指望他相信，但他连说都不肯说。[笑]
Wait, he wouldn't say--
等等，他不肯说——
Like he wouldn't even just say I was the only person for him. Like he couldn't even--
就像他连说我是他唯一的爱人都做不到。他甚至无法——
He had to get all scientific.
他非得搞得那么科学。
Yeah, exactly. He had to get all scientific. Like he couldn't just lie for a second.
是的，没错。他非得搞得那么科学。就像他连撒个谎都不行。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It's just like a fundamental difference, you know? Like to me, it makes me feel good to think that we're the only ones out there for each other. And to him, I think it makes him feel bad. I think it freaks him out. I think the idea that, like, I'm it, in the whole world, makes him feel really-- I don't know. It just seems impossible and stupid, and not-- and also, just like, it's a lot of pressure.
这简直是一个根本性的分歧，你知道吗？对我来说，认为我们是彼此的唯一让我感觉很好。而对他来说，我想这让他感觉很糟。这让他抓狂。我认为“我是他的唯一，在这个世界上”这个想法让他感觉真的很……我不知道。这看起来似乎不可能且愚蠢，而且……还有，这压力太大了。
Yeah. It's a lot of pressure. There's a saying that goes something like, "How terrible to love what can perish." You know?
是啊。这压力太大了。有句谚语大概是说：“爱上会消逝的东西是多么可怕。”你知道吗？
Right. Right. Exactly. But like, you know, there's like 100,000 people. It's not that terrible to love something that can perish. [LAUGHS]
对。对。正是如此。但就像，你知道，有10万人呢。爱上会消逝的东西并没有那么可怕。[笑]
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. Today on our show, stories of people looking for and finding the one person out there who is just for them, even if it is just a pleasant lie that there is just one person out there for each of us. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行。今天在我们的节目中，讲述那些寻找并找到命中注定之人的故事，即使“每个人都有唯一一人”只是一个美好的谎言。请继续收听。
Act One, "It's Not Over Till the Fat Man Sings." What's amazing about this guy who you're about to hear next is that he kind of decides that this girl is for him, and he pursues this girl against some really tough odds, even before he's fully in love with the girl. Sarah Koenig tells what happened.
第一幕，“不到胖子歌唱完就不算结束”。你接下来要听到的这个家伙，最令人惊奇的是，他认定那个女孩就是他的真命天女，并且他在胜算极其渺茫的情况下追求她，甚至在那时还没完全爱上她。莎拉·柯尼格讲述了发生的一切。
This romance begins with a man named Bao Gong, a strong, masculine man. An incorruptible judge.
这段罗曼史始于一个名叫包公的男人，一个强壮、阳刚的男人。一位铁面无私的法官。
Bao Gong was a famous character in Beijing Opera. And In 1995, he was played, briefly, by a 6'3" 250-pound white guy from the Midwest named Eric Hayot.
包公是京剧中的著名角色。1995年，这个角色由一位来自中西部、身高6英尺3英寸（约1.9米）、体重250磅（约113公斤）的白人小伙埃里克·海约特短暂地扮演过。
And then there was the really-- there was this fast part where he's reading the scroll. It was like-- [SINGING]
还有那段非常……那段他在读圣旨的快板部分。就像是——[唱歌]
Oh, now I'm not going to remember the rest. I don't know where it goes. I thought I could handle it. But it's something like that.
哦，我不记得剩下的部分了。我不知道它怎么唱。我原以为我能搞定。但大概就是那样的。
Eric didn't really set out to sing the part of Bao Gong. He was 23 years old at the time and on an exchange program in Tianjin, learning Chinese. He took an opera class on a lark, and after a couple of months of baffling rehearsals, found himself on stage dressed in a heavy silken and velvet robe, head shaved, face completely covered in black, red, and white makeup, and hanging down like a thick curtain from his chin, a perfectly straight, two-foot-long black beard.
埃里克并不是真的打算去唱包公这个角色。他当时23岁，正在天津参加交流项目，学习中文。他一时兴起参加了京剧课，在经历了几个月令人困惑的排练后，发现自己站在了舞台上，身穿沉重的丝绒长袍，剃光了头，脸上涂满了黑、红、白相间的脸谱，下巴上挂着帘子般厚重、笔直、两英尺长的黑胡须。
To prepare for this moment, Eric's teacher had given him a cassette tape of the part, singing the entire thing and even imitating the instruments so Eric would know his cues.
为了准备这一刻，埃里克的老师给了他一盘磁带，录下了整个唱段，甚至模仿了乐器伴奏，好让埃里克知道他的 cue 点。
And I had no idea what those sounds referred to. I'd actually never heard the objects that made those sounds. And then on the tape, there'd be this-- "Tsung, xie, xie, tsung, xie, xie, tsung." And then I was supposed to start singing, right?
但我根本不知道那些声音代表什么。我甚至从未听过发出这些声音的乐器。磁带里会有这种声音——“锵，些，些，锵，些，些，锵。”然后我该开始唱了，对吧？
He would also sing, like, "Nong-er, ning-er, ning-er, nong. A-long, dong, dinger dong." And so all this stuff. And I was like, I don't know what that is, but OK. And I knew I wasn't supposed to sing it, right? But I kind of-- so then we walk in, and there's an instrument going-- not exactly "Nong-er, nong-er, ning-er, nong," but something like it.
他也会唱，像“弄儿，宁儿，宁儿，弄。啊弄，冬，丁格咚。”之类的一切。我就想，我不知道那是什么，但好吧。而且我知道我不应该唱那个词，对吧？但我有点……所以我们走进去，那边有个乐器在演奏——并不完全是“弄儿，弄儿，宁儿，弄”，但类似那样。
[INSTRUMENT PLAYING]
[器乐演奏]
The sound was coming from a jing erhu, a two-stringed instrument that's played upright with a horsehair bow. And playing it across the rehearsal room from Eric that day was a 19-year-old musician named Yuanyuan Di.
声音来自京二胡，一种直立演奏、用马尾弓拉弦的二弦乐器。那天在排练室里，在埃里克对面拉琴的是一位19岁的音乐家，叫狄媛媛（音译）。
I mean I remember-- I just could not stop looking at her. And it was incredibly intense. I remember, I couldn't stop staring at her. And I mean, this is a ridiculous thing to remember. Her back was very, very, very straight. Just something about her posture was incredibly compelling to me.
我的意思是，我记得……我就是忍不住一直看着她。那真的非常强烈。我记得，我无法停止盯着她看。我的意思是，这真是个荒唐的记忆。她的背挺得非常、非常、非常直。她那种姿态本身就对我有着不可思议的吸引力。
And she just looked very beautiful, and she was incredibly beautiful. And so I was sitting on the other side of the room, trying to figure out how I was going to get to meet her, knowing that my Chinese was not adequate to the task of actually having a conversation with her.
她看起来非常漂亮，而且她确实美极了。所以我就坐在房间的另一边，绞尽脑汁想着怎么才能认识她，尽管我知道我的中文水平还不足以和她进行真正的对话。
I'm going to go ahead and kill the suspense right here and tell you that Eric gets the girl. So of course, they did meet. Yuanyuan's teacher introduced them. Here's Yuanyuan.
我要直接打破悬念告诉你们，埃里克确实追到了那个女孩。所以当然，他们见面了。媛媛的老师介绍了他们。这是媛媛。
I'm not used to seeing such a tall and a big person in my life, so I felt a little intimidated by having to look up all the time. So yeah, it's the first time in talking to a foreign-looking and a foreign-speaking person. I was a little nervous, yeah.
我生活中没见过这么高大的人，所以我得一直仰着头看他，觉得有点被压迫感。所以是的，这是我第一次和一个长相和语言都像外国人的人交谈。我有点紧张，是的。
Somehow they agreed to meet outside rehearsal. Neither remembers much about that first encounter, except that it was pleasant and proper, and there was a dictionary in constant use. Their first real date was for lunch.
不知怎么地，他们约定在排练外见面。两人都不记得那次初次见面的细节，除了当时气氛愉快、得体，还有一本一直用着的字典。他们的第一次真正约会是午餐。
Yuanyuan invited him to a fancy restaurant. It was her first time ever eating at such an expensive place. They both tried hard to be sophisticated, but the culture divide nearly defeated them.
媛媛邀请他去了一家高档餐厅。这是她第一次在这么贵的地方吃饭。他们俩都极力表现得老练，但文化隔阂差点让他们败下阵来。
She was doing this very Chinese thing, which is to order crazy amounts of food, just crazy amounts of food. I mean, like 10 dishes for two people. I mean like an enormous amount of food. And also, the weirder and more exotic stuff is, the more kind of you're showing your hospitality.
她在做这件非常中国的事，就是点数量疯狂的食物，简直是疯了。我的意思是，两个人点了10道菜。我的意思是那种巨大的食物量。而且，东西越奇怪、越异国情调，就越能体现你的好客。
And I ordered something, some kind of a bird, either a pigeon or even smaller bird, that is maybe deep-fried with every part on the table? And for Chinese people, lot of people do eat every part. The feet, the head, the eyes, and so on.
我点了某种东西，某种鸟，可能是鸽子或更小的鸟，可能是油炸的，所有部位都在盘子里？对中国人来说，很多人确实吃所有部位。脚、头、眼睛等等。
And so I was just eating stuff, and I had no idea what I was eating. And so at one point, I put this thing in my mouth.
于是我就在那吃，根本不知道自己在吃什么。有一次，我把这东西放进嘴里。
And he just casually carry on the conversation and put the head into his mouth.
他就在那随意地聊着天，把头放进了嘴里。
And I bite down, and it's hard. And I think, oh, no. Like, what is this thing? And then I thought, well maybe it's like an M&M, and if I suck on it, it'll disintegrate. You know, because I had no idea, right? So I kind of, you know-- [SUCKING NOISE]-- suck on it for a while.
我咬了一口，很硬。我想，噢，不。这到底是什么鬼东西？然后我想，好吧，也许它像M&M巧克力豆，如果我含着它，它就会化掉。你知道的，因为我根本不知道，对吧？所以我有点……[吸吮声]……含了一会儿。
I was thinking, wow, he must really like it. I don't eat head. I know my mom eats, but I absolutely hate it. I don't even want to look at it.
我心想，哇，他一定很喜欢。我不吃头。我知道我妈吃，但我绝对讨厌它。我连看都不想看。
And so I'm like, oh, I'm going to have to take this out of my mouth. And you know, that's not great. And so I take it out of my mouth and I put it on the plate, and I point at the dish it came from. And I say to Yuanyuan, "What is that?" And she says, "Oh, it's blah, blah, blah," right? This word that I had never heard.
所以我心想，噢，我得把它从嘴里拿出来。你知道的，这不太好。于是我把它从嘴里拿出来放在盘子上，指着盛它的那道菜。我问媛媛：“那是什么？”她说：“噢，是某某某，”对吧？这个词我从来没听过。
And I say, well, what's that? And she says the word or the thing that it is. And at precisely the instant which I grasped that word, I have this kind of total epiphanic clarity of the object on the plate in front of me, which is the head, with beak and eye, of a bird.
我问，那是什么？她说出了那个词或者它是什么东西。就在我理解那个词的那一瞬间，我对盘子里的物体产生了一种完全的顿悟——那就是鸟的头，带着喙和眼睛。
Right? Like this just terrifying thing that I had sucked on, let me just say. So like, whatever brains were in the bird, I ate those, right? And so, like, all of that came to me.
对吧？就像那种极其恐怖的东西我居然还含过，让我说吧。所以，无论那鸟脑子里有什么，我全都吃了，对吧？所以，所有这些（画面）都涌向我。
And I freak out. Just saying over and over, in a really high-pitched, kind of squealy, frightened voice, "Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god," in English.
我崩溃了。一遍又一遍地用那种极其尖锐、刺耳、惊恐的声音说着英语：“噢天哪，噢天哪，噢天哪。”
"Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god," many, many times, repeatedly, one after the other. And his hands just sprung up in the air and down. And I didn't know what was happening. I was just thinking, why was he so dramatically upset with the bird head?
“噢天哪，噢天哪，噢天哪，”重复了很多次，接连不断。他的手就在空中挥舞着。我不知道发生了什么。我只是在想，他为什么会对鸟头有这么大的反应？
I had no idea. So if you don't eat it, you just don't put it in your mouth. But why so scared?
我根本不知道。所以如果你不吃它，你就别把它放进嘴里。但为什么这么害怕？
They had a couple more dates, even though they both knew it couldn't possibly go anywhere. Eric was leaving China in two weeks. They spent a day in Beijing, where he almost lost her in a crowded train station. And she invited him to an opera performance. But Tianjin flooded that day, and it took him hours to reach her, slogging through the filthy water in bare feet.
他们又约会了几次，尽管他们都知道这不可能有什么结果。埃里克两周后就要离开中国了。他们在北京度过了一天，他差点在一个拥挤的火车站丢了她。她还邀请他去看京剧表演。但那天天津发大水了，他赤着脚在肮脏的水里挣扎了几个小时才找到她。
And I remember, at the time, that she was not nearly impressed enough by my having walked through the flood. I remember thinking-- like, she saw me, and she was like, oh, hey, how are you doing? And I'd been trying for literally two hours to get to her, right? And she was just like, oh, good to see you.
我记得，当时她对我冒着洪水走来并没有表现出足够的惊叹。我记得心想——她见到我时，表现得就像，噢，嘿，你怎么样？而我真的花了整整两个小时才找到她，对吧？而她只是说，噢，很高兴见到你。
But that desperation of, like, needing to find the person. I remember that twice, really intensely, both on the day of the flood and the day of the train station, just the sense that you have to find this person. And you know, that kind of is overwhelming.
但那种非找到那个人不可的绝望感。我记得两次，非常强烈，一次是在洪水那天，一次是在火车站那天，就是那种非找到这个人不可的感觉。你知道，那种感觉是压倒性的。
I'm teaching Proust this week, and so there's this moment in Proust where Swann is falling in love with Odette. But the way he realizes that he's falling in love with her is he goes to the party that he's supposed to meet her at, and she's already gone. And then he drives his carriage through Paris, and he's going in and out of all these restaurants, and stuff. And it's all about how the act of looking for her causes him, in some sense, not only to recognize that he's in love with her, but also actually to kind of really fall in love with her.
这周我在教普鲁斯特，普鲁斯特里有这样一个时刻，斯旺正在爱上奥黛特。但他意识到自己爱上她的方式是他去参加预定要见她的聚会，而她已经走了。然后他驾着马车穿过巴黎，进进出出所有那些餐厅之类的。这全关于寻找她的行为如何使他不仅在某种意义上意识到自己爱上了她，而且实际上也让他真的爱上了她。
Eric wasn't in love with Yuanyuan, exactly, but he was in serious crush. And then he went home to America and more or less let it go. She wrote a letter and he answered it, and she wrote again, and he never even read the second letter. It was just too much work deciphering the Chinese. So that was that.
埃里克并没有真正爱上媛媛，但他确实非常迷恋。然后他回到了美国，或多或少地放弃了。她写了一封信，他回复了，她又写了一次，但他连第二封信都没读。解读中文实在太费力了。事情就是这样。
Yuanyuan went off to conservatory in Beijing to study the jing erhu and opera, and didn't think too much about Eric, either. After all, they hadn't kissed or anything. Hadn't even held hands.
媛媛去了北京的音乐学院学习京二胡和京剧，也没怎么想起埃里克。毕竟，他们没亲吻过或什么的。甚至连手都没拉过。
But two years later, in 1997, Eric decided to go back to China to study, this time for a year. He started thinking about Yuanyuan again.
但两年后的1997年，埃里克决定回中国读书，这次待一年。他又开始想念媛媛了。
I certainly had kind of dreamed, imagined, fantasized, whatever, about getting together with her. I also knew that, you know, it was two years, and that we hadn't talked.
我当然梦想过、想象过、幻想过，等等，关于和她在一起。我也知道，你知道，隔了两年了，而且我们没联系过。
Did you feel like you even knew her, considering the language barrier and the cultural barrier? Do you know what I mean? Did you feel like you had a sense of who she was, even?
考虑到语言障碍和文化障碍，你觉得你真的了解她吗？你知道我的意思吗？你觉得你甚至了解她是个什么样的人吗？
You know, that's a really good question. You know, I don't know. No. I mean, I guess looking back now, no, right? I don't think that-- if you'd asked me that at the time, I would have denied it vociferously.
你知道，这真是个好问题。你知道，我不知道。不。我的意思是，我猜现在回过头来看，不，对吧？我不认为——如果你当时问我这个问题，我会激烈地否认。
But I mean, what could I know? I mean, what did I know? I knew her smile. I knew, like, the angle of her back. But I honestly hadn't really thought it out too much. I was pretty focused on finding her and hadn't really thought past the finding her.
但我还能知道什么？我的意思是，我知道什么？我了解她的微笑。我知道她背部的线条。但我真的没有想得太透彻。我当时非常专注于找到她，并没有想过找到她之后的事。
And so I had her phone number. So I called that number, and I got a "this number's been disconnected" message. Right? Though I barely understood, so I had to actually call three or four times to listen to the message, the person speaking.
所以我留着她的电话号码。于是我拨打了那个号码，听到“此号码已暂停服务”。对吧？虽然我几乎听不懂，但我不得不拨了三四次，去听语音、去听那个说话的人。
And so then I was lost, right? I had no way to find her. And so I guess I decided I would go and look for her.
所以我彻底丢了，对吧？我没有办法找到她。于是我猜我决定去寻找她。
This is an insanely ambitious proposition. Beijing is a city of roughly 15 million people. There are probably more than 100 universities there. And all Eric's got is her name, her picture, and the fact that she plays the jing erhu. There's no phone book, no internet. But he doesn't think any of that matters.
这是一个极其雄心勃勃的提议。北京是一个有着约1500万人口的城市。那里可能有超过100所大学。而埃里克手里只有她的名字、她的照片，以及她会拉京二胡的事实。没有电话簿，没有互联网。但他认为这些都不重要。
So a few days after he arrives in Beijing, he simply asks around for the name of a university with a good music department. Then he gets in a cab, shows the driver the address. His Chinese is terrible at this point, but he remembers the word for office, and so finds his way to the music department and asks about Yuanyuan Di. A nice older lady informs him that Yuanyuan isn't a student there, but why doesn't he try another place, an opera school?
所以在他抵达北京几天后，他只是到处询问哪里有好的音乐学院。然后他跳上一辆出租车，给司机看了地址。他当时的中文糟透了，但他记得“办公室”这个词，于是找到了音乐系并询问狄媛媛。一位好心的女士告诉他媛媛不是那里的学生，但他为什么不试试另一个地方，戏曲学校呢？
So he gets in another cab, which gets lost and then finally finds it. And Eric goes to the office of the second music school. It's a middle and high school, but Eric doesn't know that.
于是他跳上另一辆出租车，绕了路，最后找到了地方。埃里克去了第二所音乐学校的办公室。那是一所中专，但埃里克不知道。
And I start explaining, you know, who I am. So I'm like, excuse me, I'm sorry to bother you. And there's like four or five people there, and they're all smoking. They're all drinking tea. It's kind of classic Chinese afternoon, no one's working, kind of thing. And one person's kind of dealing with me, but everyone's just totally paying attention, because it's weird.
我开始解释，你知道，我是谁。我说，不好意思，打扰了。那里大概有四五个人，他们都在抽烟。他们都在喝茶。这是一种典型的中国下午，没人在干活。一个人在跟我应付，但每个人都非常关注，因为这很奇怪。
And I have the photo, and I have Yuanyuan's name. And I'm explaining that I met this young woman a couple years ago in Tianjin, and I was singing Chinese opera. And like, oh, you sing Chinese opera? I was like, well, a little bit, and I'm not very good at it. And they all laugh. And this is like part of my trick.
我有照片，还有媛媛的名字。我解释说我几年前在天津认识了这个年轻姑娘，我当时在唱京剧。他们说，噢，你会唱京剧？我说，嗯，会一点，但我唱得不太好。他们都笑了。这是我的小伎俩的一部分。
Eric's trick, what he was banking on, was his erstwhile stardom. Two years earlier, when he had sung the part of Bao Gong, the famous judge, he had become momentarily famous. He was all over the radio and on TV, talking and singing. Even Yuanyuan's grandparents had seen his picture in the papers.
埃里克的小伎俩，他所依仗的是他曾经的“明星地位”。两年前，当他扮演著名法官包公时，他曾短暂地出名过。他在电台和电视上随处可见，在谈论和唱歌。连媛媛的祖父母都在报纸上见过他的照片。
So when faced with any difficult situation in China, he knew he had this secret power, which he could deploy at will. Apparently, Chinese people really like seeing foreigners do Chinese stuff. Kung fu, calligraphy--
所以在中国面对任何困难时，他知道他有一种秘密力量，可以随时使用。显然，中国观众真的很喜欢看外国人做中国的事。功夫、书法——
And they really, really like seeing foreigners sing Chinese songs, to the point that there was a show on television every year called Foreigners Sing Chinese Songs .
而且他们非常、非常喜欢看外国人唱中文歌，以至于电视上每年都有一个节目叫《外国人唱中国歌》。
Like a special?
像一个特辑？
Like a special, yeah. Like the once-a-year special, Foreigners Sing Chinese Songs. And, you know, there's no equivalent of that in the United States. And so there's this fascination, and the fascination is two-fold, right? The fascination, first, comes from a sense of a kind of cultural inferiority, especially at the time, which any Western investment in things Chinese was taken to be a sign of respect.
像个特辑，是的。一年一度的特辑，《外国人唱中国歌》。在美国没有对应的节目。所以有一种迷恋，这种迷恋是双重的，对吧？首先，这种迷恋源于一种文化上的自卑感，特别是在那个时期，任何西方人对中国事物的投入都被视为一种尊重的标志。
And then, but also very clearly a sense of, like, watch the monkey sing a song. I mean, you know, it doesn't matter how well the monkey sings. Because if the monkey's singing a song, that's already impressive, because it's a monkey and it's a song, right?
但也很明显有一种心理，就像“看猴子唱歌”。我的意思是，猴子唱得好不好并不重要。因为只要猴子在唱歌，那就已经很令人印象深刻了，因为它是猴子，而且它在唱歌，对吧？
So knowing what I did about how much Chinese love Peking opera, and these people I'd never seen-- so I figured if I could make this happen. And I end up singing for them.
所以我知道中国人多么热爱京剧，而我以前没见过这些人——所以我想如果我能让这一切发生。最后我为他们唱了。
Again, here's that fast part.
再次，就是那段快板。
[SINGING OPERA]
[唱京剧]
It works. Everybody claps. Everyone's happy. He ends up hanging out with the staff for two hours. And finally, someone calls someone else, and it turns out Yuanyuan's former teacher happens to be at the high school that day.
奏效了。每个人都鼓掌。每个人都很开心。他最后和工作人员待了两个小时。最后，有人打了电话，结果发现媛媛以前的老师那天碰巧就在这所学校。
And all of a sudden, Eric gets news. Yuanyuan has graduated from the conservatory, which anyway is in a different building, a half hour away. But he's got her beeper number. And then it takes three days where to figure out how to beep her properly.
突然之间，埃里克得到了消息。媛媛从音乐学院毕业了，学院在另一栋楼里，半小时路程。但他拿到了她的寻呼机号码。然后又花了三天弄清楚如何正确地呼她。
And meanwhile, Yuanyuan has stopped responding to the beep. She thinks maybe a friend is playing a trick on her. But finally, they connect on the phone. Yuanyuan is stunned.
而与此同时，媛媛停止回复传呼。她以为可能是有朋友在恶作剧。但最后，他们通了电话。媛媛惊呆了。
He said his name. I thought, couldn't be. But how could he know my phone number? How could he even call me? That's impossible.
他说出了名字。我心想，不可能。但他怎么知道我的电话号码？他怎么可能打给我？这太不可思议了。
I tried to ask all these questions, but he clearly lost almost all his Chinese language. So he couldn't really explain things. So he said, could you meet me? I said yes, when? He said, tomorrow? I said, sure.
我试着问所有这些问题，但他几乎完全忘了中文。所以他真的没法解释。于是他说，你能见我吗？我说好，什么时候？他说，明天？我说，当然。
She's more than an hour late, and sure he'll be gone by the time she arrives. But he isn't. He's sitting there, waiting.
她迟到了一个多小时，肯定以为他到时会走掉。但他没有。他坐在那儿，等着。
He looks different to her. He's got hair on his head and his face. And she looks different to him, too. Not as luminous as she'd been in his imagination. But they have a nice walk, and now that he's got a whole year in China, they start spending time together. A lot of time.
他看起来和她印象中不同。他头上和脸上有了毛发。她在他眼中看起来也不同。没有他在想象中那么光彩照人。但他们愉快地散了步，现在他有一整年时间待在中国，他们开始花时间在一起。很多时间。
And as the weeks go by, Eric is trying to figure out how to kiss her-- Surprisingly difficult.
随着几周过去，埃里克在试图弄清楚该如何亲吻她——令人惊讶地困难。
She just did not help me, like, at all. I mean like at all, at all. And so I would try to do these things that were like-- OK, so this is a perfect example of why things were confusing.
她根本不给我任何帮助，一点也没有。我的意思是，一点、一点也没有。所以我会试着做那些……好吧，这是一个为什么事情很困惑的完美例子。
So we're walking down a street. I nudge her with my shoulder, the way that you do, like, when you're flirting with someone, right? She-- I only find this out later, because we talked about it. She thinks, oh, like, he's kind of a clumsy walker. I should move further away from him. I nudge her again. She thinks, oh, maybe he's trying to tell me I should walk on the other side of him, and she switches sides.
我们走在街上。我用肩膀碰她，就像你和人调情时会做的那样，对吧？她——我后来才知道，因为我们谈过，她当时想，噢，他走路怎么这么笨拙。我该离他远点。我又碰了她一下。她心想，噢，也许他是在暗示我该走在他另一边，于是她换到了另一边。
So she's, like, totally incapable of reading the codes. I mean, just like last week, we were watching a movie where some guy nudged some woman, and I was like, hey, see that? See that? That's how it works. That's how you know, right? But she had just no capacity.
所以她完全无法解读这些代码。就像上周，我们看电影时有个男的推了女的一下，我说，嘿，看到了吗？看到了吗？那就是它运作的方式。那就是你如何知道，对吧？但她完全没有这种能力。
I sensed that he wanted to kiss me, but I was not ready, or shy, or just tried to shy away. So I just tried to pretend I didn't pick up the signal, I guess.
我感觉到他想亲我，但我还没准备好，或者很害羞，或者只是试图避开。所以我想我只是假装我没收到信号。
Had you kissed another boy before then?
在那之前你亲过别的男生吗？
No.
没有。
So that was your first kiss.
所以那是你的初吻。
Yeah.
是的。
Eventually Yuanyuan heard all the details of how Eric tracked her down. He was hoping she would think it was romantic, how he searched for her, and her alone, in a city of so many millions. Nope.
最后媛媛听到了埃里克如何追踪她的所有细节。他希望她会觉得这很浪漫，他是如何在几百万人的城市里寻找她、只寻找她一个人。并没有。
First thing came to mind was crazy. I wouldn't do the same. Yeah. I thought, why would you go through all this trouble? Because people are everywhere. Why do you want to go through the trouble just to find one particular person?
脑子里闪过的第一个念头是：疯了吧。我就不会这样做。是的。我想，你为什么要费这么大周折？因为人到处都是。你为什么要为了找一个人而去费这番周折？
If this is a-- reverse the story, I was in Eric's position, I wouldn't do the same at all. Still, it's kind of a puzzle to me. [LAUGHS] I wouldn't go to a huge city trying to track down one person. I just think that's too much work. He's more romantic than I am. I'm more practical.
如果是……反转故事，我处于埃里克的位置，我根本不会那样做。但这对我来说仍然是个谜。[笑] 我不会去一个巨大的城市试图追踪一个人。我只是觉得那太费力了。他比我更浪漫。我更务实。
More practical, and also more Chinese.
更务实，也更中国化。
I think there's a saying in Chinese. It's [CHINESE]. It means what is meant to be is meant to be. You don't have to look really hard, especially when it comes to relationships. There's a specific time and location that are meant for the two of you to meet to get together, and you just have to wait for your turn. And that's something you cannot request, basically.
我想中文里有个成语。是“缘分”。意思是命中注定的事就是注定的。你不必刻意去寻找，特别是在人际关系方面。有一个特定的时间和地点注定你们两个人会相遇、走到一起，你只需要等待你的那一刻。基本上，那是你无法强求的。
After Eric left China that year, Yuanyuan came to the States on a 90-day fiancee visa, meaning if they didn't get married within 90 days, she'd have to leave, and probably not be able to return. So they did get married. But neither of them was really ready at the time.
在那一年埃里克离开中国后，媛媛持90天未婚妻签证来到了美国，这意味着如果他们不在90天内结婚，她就得离开，而且可能无法再回来。所以他们结婚了。但两人当时都没做好真正准备。
And in the first few years, Eric says it was really hard. The novelty had worn off, and the framework of their entire relationship was an ocean away. And now here they were, realizing they didn't actually know each other all that well. During that time, they often found themselves telling people the story of how they met and fell in love.
在最初的几年里，埃里克说这真的很艰难。新鲜感消失了，他们整个关系的根基隔着一个大洋。现在他们在这里，意识到他们并没有真正了解对方。在那段时间里，他们经常给人们讲述他们如何相遇并坠入爱河的故事。
And I think we lived on that, and it helped us. And it helped us be brave. You know, and reinforced to us, to each other, this sense of the magic of our relationship, and the sort of fairytale nature of it. And I think that we needed that more. Right? Like you think, like, oh, you know, a story that starts that way, how could it end up badly?
我想我们靠那个生活，它帮助了我们。它帮助我们变得勇敢。你知道的，并且向我们、向彼此强化了这种关系的神奇感，以及它的童话本质。我认为我们需要那个。对吧？就像你心想，噢，你知道，一个以那种方式开始的故事，怎么可能结局糟糕呢？
After going through those rough years, when they even considered splitting up, the story of how they met came to feel less and less important, and they didn't talk about it as much. Now they have a different story.
在经历了那些艰难的岁月，甚至考虑过分手后，他们如何相遇的故事变得越来越不重要了，他们也不怎么再提了。现在他们有了另一个故事。
Which is the story of struggle, and pain passed through and fought through and overcome. And you know, that's a story that you don't tell in public. Because no one ever asks, how did you two stay together? Everyone always asks, how did you two meet?
那就是关于奋斗的故事，关于通过痛苦、抗争并克服痛苦的故事。你知道，那是你不会在公开场合讲的故事。因为没人会问，你们俩是怎么坚持在一起的？每个人都会问，你们是怎么认识的？
Minus the singing, and the long black beard, and the jing erhu, and the beeper, and all the rest of it, Eric and Yuanyuan had to make that same transition that all couples do, from the crazy-in-love stage to the other thing. The hard part of love. And it's when you're in that struggle that you most need the story of how you're meant to be. Because the alternative, that the person you're with could be any one of hundreds or thousands of other people-- well, if that's true, then why even try?
除去唱歌、长黑胡须、京二胡、寻呼机以及所有这一切，埃里克和媛媛必须经历所有情侣都要经历的那种过渡，从疯狂恋爱的阶段转到另一种东西。爱的艰难部分。正是当你处于这种挣扎中时，你最需要那个“你们命中注定在一起”的故事。因为替代的假设——和你在一起的人可能是成百上千个其他人中的任意一个——嗯，如果那是真的，那为什么还要努力呢？
Sarah Koenig is one of the producers of our show. Coming up-- OK, if you found the one, the one for you, the one you've been looking for, how can you still be number two? Answers in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
莎拉·柯尼格是我们节目的制片人之一。即将到来——好的，如果你找到了那个“唯一”，那个适合你的、你一直在寻找的“唯一”，你怎么还能是“第二位”？芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台将在节目继续时为你解答，一分钟后。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show-- "Somewhere Out There." Stories of people searching for that one person who'll understand them in a way that nobody else does. We've arrived at Act Two of our show now. Act Two, "My Girlfriend's Boyfriend."
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们会选择一个主题，带给你关于这个主题的各种各样的故事。今天的节目——“在某处”。那些寻找唯一一个能以其他人无法做到的方式理解他们的人的故事。我们现在到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“我女友的男友”。
Comedian Mike Birbiglia has this story of some of the extreme things that some of us put up with when we believe that we have found the one person in the world for us. He recorded this in front of a live audience. And quick warning-- there's not really any sexual, prurient content in this story, but Mike does refer to the fact that sex exists and happens between people.
喜剧演员迈克·比比利亚讲了这个关于我们当中一些人当相信自己找到了世界上那个“唯一”时所忍受的一些极端事情。他在现场观众面前录制了这个节目。简要警告——这个故事里并没有什么色情、淫秽的内容，但迈克确实提到了性是存在的，并且发生在人与人之间。
When I was a senior in high school, I had my first girlfriend, Amanda. And this was a big deal for me, because it was that first time you fall in love, where you're like, oh, there is someone for me. You know, this is it. I've found her.
我高四时有了第一个女朋友，阿曼达。这对我很重要，因为那是你第一次坠入爱河，你会想，噢，有适合我的人了。你知道，就是这个。我找到了她。
And she was great. She was so beautiful, and she played tennis, and she wrote for the newspaper, and she was a bad girl. And I was a kind of dorky nerd, kind of an outcast. This was at a boarding school that I didn't board at.  I was only there because my family lived nearby.
她很棒。她非常漂亮，她会打网球，她为校报写稿，而且她是个坏女孩。我是一个有点书呆子的怪咖，是个被排斥的人。那是在一所我不寄宿的寄宿学校。我之所以在那里只是因为我家住得近。
And she had major street cred. She had been expelled from her previous school for dealing acid. I remember at one point, she said it was totally messed up, because it was actually this other girl who was dealing acid, and I was framed. And I was like, awesome.
她很有街头名声。她因为兜售迷幻药被前一所学校开除了。我记得有一次，她说这完全是一团糟，因为其实是另一个女孩在兜售迷幻药，我是被陷害的。我心想，太酷了。
I thought it was one of those things where we were opposites, and we knew it, and that made it more exciting. Like, where she wanted to be a writer and in student government, and I wanted to know what it was like to be cool.
我以为这就是那种我们性格互补的情况，我们知道这一点，这让它更令人兴奋。就像，她想成为作家并进入学生会，而我则想知道“酷”是什么感觉。
Well, I find that when you fall in love, you tend to overlook certain red flags. One of them was that she was a liar. And I don't mean that in an offensive way. At boarding school, lying is something of a way of life.
嗯，我发现当你坠入爱河时，你往往会忽略某些危险信号。其中之一就是她是个骗子。我并不是说这带有冒犯性。在寄宿学校，撒谎是一种生活方式。
I remember, there was this one guy in my class. He was a legendary liar. His name was Keith Robbins. And he used to lick his fingers like a bookie. He would go, "Yeah. Yeah. Nice. Nice. Nice."
我记得，我班上有个家伙。他是个传奇性的骗子。他的名字叫基思·罗宾斯。他舔手指就像个博彩经纪人。他会说：“耶。耶。不错。不错。不错。”
And he would lie about things that weren't important. Like he'd be like, "Yeah. Yeah. Nice. My uncle's Tony Robbins, motivational speaker. Yeah. Nice." And I found out later that that wasn't even true. But even if it were, it wouldn't be that impressive, you know? And so you didn't bother protesting it. You'd just go, "Oh, OK, Keith."
他会撒一些不重要的谎。他会说：“耶。耶。不错。我叔叔是托尼·罗宾斯，励志演说家。耶。不错。”后来我发现那根本不是真的。但即使是真的，也没什么了不起的，你懂吧？所以你没必要去反驳。你只会说：“噢，好的，基思。”
The other red flag was that Amanda used to say really mean stuff to me, and then she'd say, "Only kidding." She'd be like, "You're not good at anything. Only kidding." "Nobody likes you at all. Only kidding."
另一个危险信号是阿曼达过去常对我做刻薄的事，然后她说：“开玩笑的。”她会说：“你什么都不擅长。开玩笑的。”“根本没人喜欢你。开玩笑的。”
The final red flag was that she told me not to tell anyone she was my girlfriend. She had another boyfriend at home that she was in the process of breaking up with. And it was over, but if it got back to him, you know, it would be bad.
最后一个危险信号是她告诉我不要告诉任何人她是我的女朋友。她在家里还有个男朋友，正处于分手的过程中。事情已经结束了，但如果被他知道，你知道的，那会很糟糕。
So she would go home every weekend and visit him. And at one point she said she had to go home more frequently because his parents were sick, so she had to console him in that. And I thought, well, you know, the guy's parents are dying, so I ought to be understanding.
所以她每个周末都会回家探望他。有一次她说她必须更频繁地回家，因为他的父母生病了，所以她必须去安慰他。我想，好吧，你知道，那家伙的父母快要死了，所以我应该体谅一下。
I also put up with it because I couldn't believe how lucky I was just to be with her. Like in retrospect, I understand how selfish she was. But at the time, I didn't know that.
我也忍受了这些，因为我简直不敢相信自己能和她在一起是多么幸运。回想起来，我明白她有多自私。但在当时，我并不知道。
When you're in a relationship with someone who's selfish, what keeps you in it is the fact that when they shine on you, it's like this souped-up shine. And you feel like you're in the club, and you don't even know what the club is. You just know you want to stay in it.
当你和自私的人谈恋爱时，让你维持这段关系的是当他们对你展示好的一面时，那就像是超强力度的光芒。你会觉得你加入了某个俱乐部，而你甚至不知道那是什么俱乐部。你只知道你想留在里面。
We'd been going out two months, and we went on Christmas break. And she invited me to meet her parents in New Hampshire. And this was very exciting. This was going to be my big moment. It would vindicate me and legitimize me as the main boyfriend.
我们交往两个月了，然后放了寒假。她邀请我去新罕布什尔州见她的父母。这非常令人兴奋。这将是我生命中的重要时刻。它会证明我，并将我确立为她的正式男友。
And so I drive my mom's Volvo station wagon from Massachusetts to New Hampshire. And I meet her parents, and it's going really well. And then this guy shows up, and his name is Scott. And then the three of us are hanging out. And it dawns on me that I'm hanging out with my girlfriend's boyfriend.
于是我开着我妈的沃尔沃旅行车从马萨诸塞州到新罕布什尔州。我见了她的父母，一切进行得非常顺利。然后这个家伙出现了，他的名字叫斯科特。然后我们三个人待在一起。我突然意识到我正在和我女朋友的男朋友待在一起。
And it's going OK? He seemed like a good guy. He was an all-state wrestler. And he was remarkably nice. I could totally see what she saw in him.
而且一切还好？他看起来是个好人。他是个全州摔跤选手。而且他非常友善。我完全能看出她看中了他哪一点。
And there was some consolation, because every time he would go to the bathroom or go into the other room, she would be very affectionate towards me. She'd kiss my neck, or say something in her sweet voice. But then there was a moment where I was in the bathroom. And I thought, what's happening in the other room?
而且还有些安慰，因为每当他去洗手间或进入另一个房间时，她就会对我表现得非常亲昵。她会吻我的脖子，或者用她甜美的嗓音说些什么。但后来有一次我在洗手间。我想，另一个房间里在发生什么？
The date took a strange turn when Scott suggests that we go hang out at his house. And so we go, and I meet his parents. And it's a very strange thing, meeting your girlfriend's boyfriend's parents for the first time. Part of you is angry, for obvious reasons, and then part of you still wants to make a good impression. As a side note, they seemed in perfect health.
约会发生了一个奇怪的转折，斯科特建议我们去他家待会儿。于是我们去了，我见了她的父母。去见你女朋友的男友的父母真是件奇怪的事。你的一部分因为显而易见的原因感到愤怒，另一部分仍然想给他们留下好印象。顺便提一下，他们看起来身体非常健康。
I drive home, defeated. And I sort of knew that at this point, this was her life, and I was like her secret life, like on Maury Povich . So I was like, this is it. I'm gonna stick up for myself. It's either him or me. And I convinced myself that given that choice, she would go with me, because what we had was so special.
我开车回家，感到挫败。我在那一刻有点明白，这就是她的生活，而我就像是个像在《莫里·波维奇秀》里的秘密生活。所以我心想，就是这样。我要为自己站出来。要么他，要么我。我确信自己，给定这个选择，她会选择我，因为我们之间拥有的是如此特别。
So when we got back to school, I called her and I said, "We need to talk. Let's meet at the hockey game." And she says, "Great." So I go to the hockey game, and she's not there. Hockey game ends, still no sign. I have that pit in my stomach, you know, like, this was going to be my moment. And I was going to tell her that she had to pick me, or that's it.
所以当我们回到学校后，我打电话给她说：“我们需要谈谈。我们在冰球比赛见吧。”她说：“太好了。”于是我去看了冰球比赛，她没出现。比赛结束了，还是没见人影。我胃里那种沉重感又来了，你知道，就像，本来这将是我的时刻。我本打算告诉她，她必须选择我，否则就结束了。
And so I start walking around the school, to the library, the cafeteria, the places she might be. And I ask people where she is, and finally someone says, "I saw her with Keith Robbins down at the tennis courts." I remembered earlier that day at lunch, Keith had said to me, "I'm sleeping with your girlfriend. You know that, right?"
于是我开始在学校四处寻找，去图书馆、餐厅，她可能在的地方。我问别人她在哪里，最后有人说：“我看到她和基思·罗宾斯在网球场。”我记得那天午餐时，基思曾对我说：“我在和你女朋友睡觉。你知道吧？”
And I thought, well, first of all, I hadn't even slept with my girlfriend, so that would be insane. And second of all, he's a liar, so he must be lying. I remember I said to him, yeah, I know.
我想，首先，我甚至没跟我的女朋友睡过，所以这太疯狂了。其次，他是骗子，所以他肯定在撒谎。我记得我对他说，对，我知道。
But at this moment, it dawns on me that Keith was her new second boyfriend, and I was done. And it was that horrible lonely feeling where you're walking around someplace, and there are people all around, and there's only one person you want to be with, no matter how mean they've been to you. I just wanted to hear that "Only kidding."
但在这一刻，我意识到基思是她的新二号男友，而我完了。那是一种可怕的孤独感，你走在某个地方，周围都是人，而你唯一想在一起的人却不在，无论她对你有多刻薄。我只是想听到那句“开玩笑的”。
I remember people were coming up to me, and I couldn't even hear them. I couldn't even tell them what had happened. Because even though I was being dropped, the relationship itself was based on a secret.
我记得人们过来跟我打招呼，我甚至听不见他们在说什么。我甚至没法告诉他们发生了什么。因为尽管我被甩了，这段关系本身就是建立在秘密之上的。
And that spring, I graduated. Keith was expelled for making fake IDs in his dorm room. He had built a life-sized license from Arkansas that people stuck their face in. And he would photo it and then laminate it. He later took a job at Goldman Sachs. That detail seems made-up. It's actually true.
那个春天，我毕业了。基思因为在宿舍制作假证件被开除了。他做了一个真人大小的阿肯色州驾照，人们可以把脸凑进去。他会拍照然后塑封。他后来在高盛找到了一份工作。那个细节看起来像是虚构的。但其实是真的。
And Amanda was expelled the next year for dealing Ritalin. At boarding school, you can't go to the graduation if you're expelled. It's one of the shames of being expelled. And it's very strict. And I found out later that Amanda actually did show up to the graduation in a disguise. She wore a wig and sunglasses.
阿曼达第二年因为兜售利他林被开除了。在寄宿学校，如果你被开除，你就不能参加毕业典礼。这是被开除的耻辱之一。而且学校纪律非常严格。后来我发现阿曼达居然乔装打扮出现在了毕业典礼上。她戴着假发和墨镜。
My friends laughed about this, the way that friends do to make you feel better when you've had your heart broken. But I could relate to her doing that. Because sometimes when you want to be in a place so badly, you'll do anything.
我的朋友们嘲笑这件事，就像朋友们为了让你心情好起来而做的那样，当你的心碎了的时候。但我能理解她那样做。因为有时当你太想待在一个地方时，你会不惜一切代价。
Mike Birbiglia. That story is part of a book that he's putting together called Sleepwalk With Me: And Other Stories .
迈克·比比利亚。那个故事是他正在编撰的一本书的一部分，书名叫《梦游与我：以及其他故事》。
[MUSIC - "(I'D GO THE) WHOLE WIDE WORLD" BY WRECKLESS ERIC]
[音乐 - “整个大世界” 由 Wreckless Eric 演唱]
Well, our program today was produced today by Jane Feltes, Robyn Semien, and me, with Alex Blumberg, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer's Julie Snyder. Production help from Andy Dixon and Brian Reed.
好的，我们今天的节目由简·费尔特斯、罗宾·塞米恩和我制作，参与制作的还有亚历克斯·布伦伯格、莎拉·柯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、阿莉莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作助理是安迪·狄克逊和布莱恩·里德。
Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon is our office manager. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
塞思·林德是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理。音乐协助是杰西卡·霍珀。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia.
我们的网站是 thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ的管理层对我们的节目进行监督的是我们的老板，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。
You know, I gave Torey a tape of a recent show  and I told him he had to listen to the show. And he keeps making these excuses. He swears there is something wrong with the recording.
你知道，我给了托雷一盘近期节目的磁带，我告诉他他必须听这个节目。他一直在找借口。他发誓录音有问题。
And then on the tape, there'd be this-- "Tsung, xie, xie, tsung, xie, xie, tsung."
然后磁带里会有这种声音——“锵，些，些，锵，些，些，锵。”
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。